guten abend frau zypries
wenn wir bei den fall maddie und
christian b bleiben es gibt mittlerweile
oder es gibt noch immer keine richtigen
beweise gegen ihn ist das typisch für
kindesmissbrauch muss man jetzt davon
ausgehen dass sie am ende wahrscheinlich
so davonkommt also das hat sich aber auf
alle fälle nicht wenn das denn wahr
da gehe ich nicht von aus aber es ist
natürlich völlig richtig dass sind
delikte die im aller regel in einen
nahen stadt und für die es dann
natürlich keine zeugen gibt also es sei
denn es werden ausnahmen gemacht so wie
jetzt in dem entdeckten fall in
nordrhein westfalen das verschwinden von
maddie es 13 jahre her sehen sie diesen
fall jetzt ein versagen und wenn ja von
wem das kann ich im moment nicht
beurteilen
also hört sich ja so an als ob
bestimmten indizien nicht nachgegangen
sei worden sei das kann ich aber jetzt
ich habe dann nur zeitungswissen das
kann ich nicht sagen
dieses wochenende kam es dann kam der
schockierenden fall aus münster dann ans
licht wie schätzen sie diesen einen wie
kann es sein dass die familie fünf jahre
lang von fachleuten jugendamt und
anderen im auge behalten worden ist und
trotzdem nichts passiert ist und sie ja
diese diese schrecklichen taten einfach
so weiterführen konnten ja das fragt man
sich das ist in der tat ein großes
problem und ich nehme an das wird jetzt
auch aufgeklärt werden in nordrhein
westfalen was da und ob da ein versagen
von einrichtungen vor sich aber es ist
ja immer schwierig
die taten im nahbereich wie gesagt
öffentlich zu machen das ist eine alte
debatte als ich ministerin war aber ich
habe versucht eine anzeigepflicht zu
statuieren für kindergärtnerinnen für
erzieherinnen dass sie verpflichtet sein
sollten wenn sie verdacht haben die
polizei zu informieren gar keine anzeige
zu machen oder das jugendamt zu
informieren dass irgendjemand mal von
außen da anfängt draufzukommen dass
konnte sich damals nicht durchsetzen und
das hat sich auch bis heute nicht
durchgesetzt wird immer wieder
diskutiert aber es wird dann immer
wieder abgelehnt
bei gesagt wird da wird das
vertrauensverhältnis zu leicht zerstört
und es ist ja für viele kinder auch so
wenn sie vom vater großvater onkel
missbraucht werden dass das personen
ihres nahbereich sind und sie natürlich
nicht wollen dass der vater ins
gefängnis kommen das ist ja ein
fürchterlicher konflikten eben diese
kinder sind und deswegen wird es eben
sind differenziert diskutiert sind
gerade gesagt das wird immer weiter
diskutiert was aber auch diskutiert wird
ist ob unsere strafen gegen
kindesmissbrauch hier in deutschland
auch immer zu lasch sind wie sehen sie
das
nein das finde ich ehrlicherweise nicht
wir haben mit straftatbestände in
schweren fällen von mindestens einem
jahr das heißt da ist es ein verbrechen
in schweren fällen aber dadurch dass der
straftatbestand des sexuellen
missbrauchs von kindern ja schon das
einfache berühren von kindes genitalen
beispielsweise und fast wenn sie da
gleich mit einer mit einem verbrechen
dran gehen würden dann hätten sie einen
falls das problem dass irgendwelche
sachen nicht angeklagt würden oder
gleich anders abgehandelt werden
deswegen haben wir uns damals dafür
entschieden zu sagen es bleibt dabei
sechs monate bis ein jahr für diese
normalen ganz leichten fälle wie ich
gerade sagte berühren oder so aber in
anderen fällen ist es ein verbrechen das
stehen auch schon jetzt im gesetz